that's it
good afternoon and welcome to this joint
standards committee meeting on monday
the 6th of september 2021.
my name is councillor mark bassinger and
i am the chairman of this committee
before i take the committee through some
general housekeeping issues i would like
all in attendance to introduce
themselves please and i shall start
with mr turner
thank you i'm paul turner i'm your
acting monitoring officer for today i'm
in the absence of mr qualch
my name is chrissy morris i am
best looking voted best looking
counsellor for morgan district council
for 2019 2020 and 2021
heybridge west
good afternoon everyone i'm
richard perry i am uh
councillor morris's advocate today
i'm inexperienced so i hope you'll bear
with me
i live and work in morden at the
milhouse hotel i cook the best breakfast
in town serve the coldest moretti
and uh thank you mr perry councillor
perry thank you very much and he's also
the chairman of hey parachute excellent
can we move on
afternoon chairman councillor nb or
haybridge west uh sorry east
i don't know who i'll represent
hey bridge east
councillor fleming i represent the
pearly ward thank you
councillor richard siddall great totten
ward
good afternoon chairman members john
mitchell independent person
good afternoon everyone everybody my
name is nick skeens i'm a counsellor
representing south burnham and i'm
substituting for council stephen now
good afternoon members i'm councillor
carly mayes molden northward
good afternoon everybody my name is
peter still i'm a town councillor for
morgantown council and i'm here as the
independent person
thank you chairman casey clark to the
committee
excellent thank you members
exactly and we should now call on the
two uh virtual um members and uh could i
start with mr lewin please
um good afternoon everyone um i'm matt
lewin i'm a barrister and i investigated
the clt
complaints against councillor morris
uh hello members my name is alex auram
and i investigated uh you've got a
report from me investigating four
complaints against councillor morris and
i'm apologies for my inability to attend
today i had a my family was struck down
with covid so i thought it best to keep
that away from from moulding for the
moment hopefully
thank you
okay thank you everyone
we are streaming this meeting live
as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak i will then invite you
at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording and the interaction with
the remote attainees mr lewin
and mr orem
is dependent on the correct use of the
microphones therefore can i ask you when
invited to speak
remember to turn your microphones on and
then when you finish turn them off
um
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notice on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind the top table
item number two
apologies for absence
thank you bernard thank you chairman
we've received apologies for absence
from councillors duik jarvis and none
and as councillor schemes pointed out
he's here substituting for councillor
nan this afternoon thank you
thank you
item number three the minutes of the
last meeting
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 17th of august
2021
found on pages 3 to 10 are approved as a
true and accurate record
this will also include the amendment to
appendix 1 as agreed at council
on the 2nd of september 2021
i so move do i have a second please
counselor fleming seconded
thank you
thank you councillor fleming can we
agree those minutes
declaration of interests
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interest other
peculiar interests or non-vacunary
interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
do i have any disclosures of interest
sorry chairman before we proceed could
could we make sure that everybody leans
in and speaks very clearly with the
microphone so we've been advised online
that
the microphones within the chamber the
remote members can be heard clearly but
not from these microphones very clearly
so we can make sure that we have it in
front of us and speak really clearly so
is it just possible to bend the necks
can we do that we bend the necks a
little bit just towards us so as
everyone can hear thank you everybody
thank you very much
councillor morris
thank you mr chairman um i just like a
point of clarification because
i noticed that no member has
uh declared any interest whatsoever
and
i'd just like to ask i mean uh i believe
we all received
a uh email from councillor langan
if you wouldn't mind i'd like to read
this out because i believe that everyone
here
needs to be aware
because they may be having to declare
predetermination
thanks chrissy but i feel that you are
missing the point
of my response i certainly do not allow
you do not allow you any consent or
representation
on my behalf in anything in any way on
any issue and although you may feel that
replying to an email out of courtesy
does this i'm afraid you are
incorrect not correct in this assumption
my driver as a member is to serve the
residents of the district
and that helps and that needs a
collaborative approach not a divisive
one
we may not see eye to eye on issues
and by we i refer to all members
now i'd like to just reiterate that one
councillor langan has referred to all
members
which is every councillor in this role
excellent okay well thank you council
morris and if he has if he has referred
to all members
that would so that would basically state
that there is now pre-determination in
this room well then i should put that
independently out to the members does
anyone feel they have a declaration to
make
mr chairman what i would rather you you
you state was
has any member discussed this and come
up with a pre-determination for for for
the outcome of
this meeting with
uh councillor langan because councillor
langan has clearly stated
we
and by we are referred to all members
which is everyone in this room
that would be predetermination
that would be so let me just clarify so
in that email he has put we
he has put we i'll read it to you
and you're taking that that he's
actually asking everybody or always
colluded with everybody it seems that he
would have colluded with everybody i
mean unless you want to call councillor
lang and a liar the exact phrase mr
chairman is and by
we okay i refer to all members great
thank you very much cancer skins very
quickly
yes so um
my feeling is well certainly i have not
discussed this with anybody i certainly
haven't discussed it with uh council
lagoon or anybody else i think we're all
very well aware of the rules uh i didn't
express any
um
sense of predetermination or conflict of
interest or anything like that because i
have none uh i've known councillor
morris since he arrived here
uh and um i and so in a sense i suppose
that i could declare an interest that i
know him but that seems irrelevant here
because we all know him that's the point
so i don't think that that council
lagging's um
email can be interpreted in that way or
maybe it could be interpreted in that
way but it doesn't represent reality i
had no discussion with him he's not
speaking for every councillor thank you
thank you very much
councillor fleming
thank you chair i just wanted to ask
when that email was um
council morris
that was the um
19th of july
council fleming thank you chair um well
i have a confession to make i often
don't read these types of emails uh to
all members um apologies counselor
morris i often i don't read your emails
and i usually don't read anyone else's
emails on subjects like this and i can
assure you i'm not pre-determined
score i can concur with i actually
haven't seen that email so i'm a member
and i haven't seen that
the email was sent to all members
and
thank you very much for explaining
it's nice to know that uh you think uh
councillor langen's lying thank you
that's your opinion
uh councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman uh i'm not on the
district council website so it wouldn't
have come to me anyway thank you very
much councillor stilts um council siddal
thank you chairman uh i'm sure council
lag and refers to all members in that
email but i can uh reassure councillor
morris that i have not spoken to
councillor lagan about this particular
committee
and this particular report that's in
front of us so there is no
predetermination
thank you very much no predetermination
on your part obviously okay thank you
very much um
any such interest as soon as they become
aware should the needs rise throughout
the meeting has anyone declared an
interest
thank you very much we shall move on
thank you
number five
standards complaints
and we move
we now move to agenda item five
standards complaints counselor chrissy
morris found on pages
11-70 i call on the acting and
monitoring officer mr paul turner to
present his report and take the
committee through the process for
today's proceedings thank you mr turner
thank you chairman so
an indicative process is set out in the
agenda pack i'm following the
conversation with your chairman this
morning we're supposed to make one
slight change to that towards the end of
the process but
basically in a moment we will ask mr
orem to present his report
um
then
uh council morris and the committee will
be invited to ask any questions they
want to ask of mr orham and then we will
do the same with mr lewin and his report
and then um
council morris will be asked to make any
representations
chrissy will be asked to make any
representations that he wishes to about
whether or not he is in breach of the
code of conduct
and then mr oran mr lewis and the
committee and the independent person
will be
entitled to ask questions of
um chrissy
thank you
then
um
after that
it's proposed that
we were proposing to then go to to then
go into a um to determine whether or not
there was a breach and then if there was
finding a breach then then to hear
representations on what sanctions should
be applied but following a discussion
with your chairman is that proposed that
we should then have a conversation about
or but allow representations about what
sanctions should be applied if there is
a finding of breach so so that they the
committee don't have to exclude the
press and public twice
in which case then the independent
person will be invited to address
the
committee to give his advice both on
breach and sanction then your ukraine
will be able to give you any views on
sanction and then if mr oram and or mr
lewin would like to do so they will also
be allowed to to do the same
and then it's proposed that the
the the the principal decide whether or
not to exclude the press and public and
if so then they'll make a decision in
after that point
councillor perry
yeah thank you just i've not met you
before so i'm just wondering why you're
the monitoring officer
for this at the moment
and so i've been asked by
sorry i've been asked by milton district
council to to step in today so i think
my understanding is that there's a
conflict of interest and also mr quelch
is unavailable because he's on
because this had to be arranged at a
time when he went when he's
away from the country it's my
understanding
what conflict of interest might it be
well i think if you look at councillors
wayne's complaint he features in the
facts of it doesn't he
see i've had the problem i've got i've
had mr quelch phoning me up and uh been
liaising with me
is he acting on your behalf by following
could i also could i just step in there
um are you referring to the conversation
when mr quelch phoned you only the other
day
yes i am that was on my request
i'm just i'm just querying why mr quelch
is getting involved in this if mr quelch
isn't getting involved with this this is
an independent outside monitoring
officer mr quelch is not involved in
this i asked mr quelch to give you a
call because you asked me if you could
speak at this meeting so i'm not legally
aware if you can or cannot so i ask mr
quelch to make that point clear mr
quelst then on my behalf said he would
phone you and explain to you exactly
what and wasn't possible
the problem i've got i felt that mr
quelcher's browbeating me and pushing me
into things and he's giving me his phone
number to phone back
and now i find that
this gentleman's the monitoring officer
so but you knew this gentleman was the
monitoring officer
i don't know
as as i've
tried to explain
earlier
i tried to explain earlier i don't know
this process i've never been to one of
these things before well there is a
monitoring officer and we have an acting
monitoring officer
who is you well you've got two
monitoring officers no we haven't we
have one monitoring officer
well i was just
so would you like to please sit down
councillor perry please
um yeah mr chairman as um
is the absence of mr quelch got anything
to do with the fact that he has
threatened legal proceedings against
free members no council morris it has
not none nothing at all none whatsoever
thank you
mr turner i'd like to ask you no i'm
sorry i'm not going to let you ask mr
turner anything else at the moment i
will allow you to but just let's
leave it at that we've established that
mr turner is the monetary officer so i
do get to ask my question you will get
to ask thank you question of course
thank you mr turner
so so after this could i interrupt you
mr turn one second
councillor
thank you very much chairman
if anybody has read the report
into this investigation it clearly
states
that mr turner is the monitoring officer
and that is being put out so the fact
that your advocate has not read this
report
counselor morris is quite worried
one second mr perry would you do that
through the chair please through the
chair
i'm just i
as i spoke to you the other day i'm just
here to try and help and make things go
smoothly
you know
i haven't read the thing and i did speak
to you earlier and i came here i
counseled perry if you
come to help and you haven't read the
report
i've i've skim read it i've skimmed read
the report i know that just let's just
let's not go any further because
councillor perry hasn't been provided
with the report
this isn't something this isn't
something that um i um okay well okay
well i'm gonna leave it right there and
just say we have established that mr
turner is our monitoring officer but we
haven't just established why well then
we can and
i'd like to ask mr turner
is it usual
for 10
of the members of a council to be
threatened with legal action by the
monitoring officer is that usual mr
turner thank you please don't answer
that thank you very much
why not answer that just carry on please
why not answer that mr chairman
because i don't think that's a question
that mr turner should be answering
actually
that's why that's my discussion mr
turner is a monitoring officer if mr
quelch was here he would be the
monitoring officer i'd like to know why
he isn't here and is the reason that he
isn't here that he has
threatened legal action against three
councillors that are sitting in this
room and i know possibly more i can
actually say no
so does that answer your question no it
doesn't it doesn't give an adequate well
i don't know what else to say you ask a
question and you have an answer okay so
i've asked mr turner a question you're
not allowing him to answer it mr turner
yeah um yeah i'm i'm sorry about um
point of order that this what is being
discussed now does not relate to what is
actually in front of us i agree with you
entirely
are you all worried that your precious
counsel is
mr turn would you like to move on please
okay
so if it says i've been i i was asked
before christmas to look to to be
be the modern officer in this in this
particular case because because it was
um at the hit at the hearing because for
the reason the race is conflict of
interest
so
so you've done
mr turner is still speaking
point of order um mr turner previously
just just now
said that mr crouch was out of the
country
now this has been postponed due to
health reasons
so
this was always going to be given to
someone else and not have simon quelch
as the monitoring officer yes we did not
know the date of this
um hearing when it was given to mr
turner that's correct so why has it been
given to mr turner and is it because
three of the members here now have been
threatened with legal action by simon
quilch the monitoring officer no
mr turner
so
so after we've heard all the
representations on sanction if well if
there were to be a
um founder finding a breach then the
committee will
are likely to deliberate in private and
then
make a decision
and then that decision will be
communicated back to the
council morris
and
it's crazy sorry
how bit of a lifetime i'm afraid
so
and
so that that's um sorry
so
so that that is the process that we're
going to to follow today
um i think we're now ready to
hear from mr aurum
thank you very much hello members hello
just um
just just before i go through the report
it is relevant to complaint one um
my own knowledge on
mr quelch's uh role in this was that
um the complaint the first complaint the
members are being asked to consider
which relates to comments
councillor morris was alleged to have
made on the 13th of august 2020
um related to an allegation that he
shouted corrupt when mr holmes and mr
dodson were introduced to the meeting
the investigation when reviewing
the conduct found that he also shouted
corrupt when mr quelch
was introduced and i believe it was at
that point that mr quelch felt it would
be um more appropriate for another
monitoring officer
to be involved in considerations because
clearly his own integrity had been
questioned by chrissy
as part of that aspect of the complaint
so i hope that assists uh
with considerations
turning then to
to my report i don't intend to take
members through it line by line i i made
the assumption that members had an
opportunity to read through
the agenda papers and and the report
as it's set out
members will see that um that i was
asked or invited to
to look at four different complaints or
the report deals with four different
complaints
um and if you look at um i'm just trying
to get the right page of the agenda so
apologies for that
page 11 and 12
of your agenda papers
that sets out to come a summary of the
key issues that i was asked to
to look at
the first complaint from councillor
swain related to
an allegation
of misconduct at a planning committee
meeting on the 13th of august
the second complaint from
maddie thompson
concerned that an email exchange in
councillor morris's comments in an email
that occurred the day after that meeting
the third complaint that i was asked to
investigate
concerns
a complaint from councillor boyce about
comments councilor morris was said to
have made about him at a standard
committee meeting on the 3rd of
september
and then
on
the last matter that i was asked to
investigate concerned complaints made by
councillor penny channel
relating to councillor morris's uh
disclosure of
information
in regards to a complaint against
councillor bamford on the 29th of
october
and then on the 5th of february
relating to a telephone exchange in his
subsequent publishing of that on
facebook
now
members can find
the details of our investigation from
page 17
and
we've set out there a summary of the the
matters under investigation
and details of the legislation and
processes relevant to to our
investigation and considerations
and then from page 22
that the findings of our
investigation how we've gone about it so
i'm happy to take questions from anyone
on those matters um
when we get to that point
it isn't my intent to take you through
every single line of it as i say but
obviously in regards to complaint one we
found that councilor morris did shout
the words corrupt
when the three officers were introduced
to the meeting
with regards the second complaint
members at paragraph 4.26 of our report
which can be found on page 27
we'll see the email that councillor
heard sent
to all members following that complaint
and then most relevant to our
considerations at paragraph 4.27 they
will find councillor morris's response
to that email which is probably
all members of the council
the facts relating to complaint three
councillor voices complaint
are set out from paragraph 4.31 on page
30.
and members will see um
at paragraph 4.35
what it was that councillor morris said
at that meeting um about councillor
boyce
and then finally complaint four
the um
paragraph 4.47
sets out the post that councilor morris
left on facebook with regards to his
complaint against councillor bamford
and then paragraph
4.52
is a transcript of the conversation that
he had with councillor chana
and then 4.53 obviously he published the
recording of that on facebook and 4.53
shows the post that he left accompanying
that
so that was the first aspect of what we
were asked to do really was establish
what happened in relation to each of the
complaints
um i don't think there is much that's in
dispute but obviously we can take
questions on that and hear from chrissy
his
side of the story which i hope is set
out in our report
but i hope that members will be
confident in feeling they understand
what happened on each occasion when
having to consider subsequently whether
the code of conduct was breached
our own considerations on whether the
code was breached can be found from page
39 of the agenda pack
you will see that initially we have
set out some considerations as to
regards
whether councillor
morris was always acting in his official
capacity and therefore the code could be
applied to the conduct
um
this
is largely focused on the facebook
elements because obviously when it comes
to using social media that's where
things can become more complicated in
terms of applying code
but
based on those considerations members
will see that we have
concluded that councilor morris's
conduct with regards these four
complaints does all fall within the
scope of the code of conduct
we've gone on therefore to
consider which paragraph the code are
best applied and whether the conduct as
we found it amounts to a breach of the
code with regards to complaint one
you will see um on a page 43 of the
bundle our considerations in relation to
axl swain's complaint
we set out firstly our own definition
for what a failure to treat others with
respect looks like
members may have their own
considerations to a certain extent um
committees such as yourself have the
opportunity to set your own bar in
relation to the culture of your
organization
and decide what respectful and
disrespectful conduct looks like to each
other and to officers
our own definition is in the report and
i hope we've set out clearly why we feel
that
questioning the integrity of offices in
the manner that councillor morris did at
that meeting does amount to a failure to
show others
respect
with regard councillor thompson's
complaint
again we've considered whether his email
made
comments or included comments that were
disrespectful
and on the bottom of page 45 in
paragraph 5.29
we've specifically set out
those comments that we feel um cross
that line from being robust political
exchange
to being uh disrespectful about other
parties
with regards to the complaint against
councillor boyce and just to correct one
part of the agenda report we've actually
recommended that council morris not be
found to have failed to comply with the
code with regard this complaint now when
making this recommendation
we've been very careful to
separate the initial comments about
councillor boyce that were the focus of
those considerations at the stands
committee
and the complaint that we were being
asked to consider which was simply the
comments that councillor morris made
during that committee meeting um now we
believe that
uh it would be it would be effectively
uh considering councillor morris's
conduct twice
if we were to consider
the manner in which he defended himself
in relation to an allegation that he'd
made similar comments previously
we feel that that councillors should be
able to um
defend themselves strongly in in a
situation like this and therefore
whilst
we're not looking back at the original
comments we think that his reiteration
of them and his explanation about why he
made them during the stanza committee
meeting it was acceptable for him to do
so so we haven't actually
reached a recommended breach on that
particular complaint
but turning to fancy channel's complaint
again we have
concluded that he failed to treat her
with respect
um during the telephone call and in
particular by publishing it along with
his comments uh without her permission
um
or indeed knowledge until afterwards
point of order
do you have a point of order yeah um
uh sorry mr rohram but um you just said
without her permission i don't need her
permission there's no permission needed
there's no consent needed
thank you okay chrissy thanks thanks for
that
um
we've then gone on to consider whether
councillor morris has demonstrated uh
behaviours that we would consider of
bullying a failure to uh
or members are required not to bully or
harass others
again on page 47 we've set out
our own objective considerations on what
we think
a breach of this code looks like what
are the sorts of behaviours we would
expect to see
in order to find out that a council had
failed to comply with this aspect
and
in that regard at paragraph 5.38 on page
48
we've bullet pointed
behaviors that we believe did cross that
line again as i said earlier and
and represent um
behavior that isn't uh in line with
chrissy's uh duty to comply with the
code
similarly we've considered whether uh
chrissy's behavior um brought his office
or authority into disrepute and members
will see on pages 48 and 49 our own
considerations and thoughts on that
and then finally in relation to
complaint four um we've decided we've
considered whether councillor morris's
disclosure with regards
um councillor bam the complaint about
councillor bamford did represent a
disclosure of confidential information
and again i hope we've set out clearly
to members our own considerations and
thoughts
and reasoning as to why we do believe
that that was a disclosure of
confidential information
so i'm happy to take any questions that
member or
may have with regard any aspect of
those
complaints great thank you mr orem um
i shall go to councillor stilts
of schemes sorry i beg your pardon
yes sir thank you very much for your
report on the uh penny channel issue
councillor
penny channel uh we've just heard
council morris say that there's no legal
requirement for him to give notice what
is your opinion on this and is this a
question of legal requirement or is it a
question of code could you explain how
there is a breach of a code if he has
called councillor chana as we know that
he did
taken her through a series of
accusations
and then published that on the website
is what's the legal
issue here is it illegal as count
or is it not
i i wouldn't be in a position to offer
legal advice it may be that the the
acting monitoring officer can can do
that um in relation to code of conduct
issues um
it it can
relate simply to what has been said
about councillor chana but i think there
is a point of principle here which is
where the members can trust each other
to have conversations
um
where
they can be open with each other in a
belief that what they're talking about
um
isn't in public
and that trust is clearly broken when
when a uh a
a one of those members subsequently you
find out that they've recorded and
published
that conversation
i can see how it can have a detrimental
impact on the ability of councillors to
actually work well together
cancer schemes if i could come back
absolutely
yes uh it certainly could um
by this stage i think uh
chrissy had become pretty well known for
making such phone calls and publishing
them on the
social media and i'm not suggesting for
a moment that council china should have
known that but it was generally
his modus operandi
i'm just finding myself wondering
exactly where in the code does it say
that you cannot phone and call up a coun
a counselor have a conversation with
them and then publishing it on the on
the internet but it's important to know
for the future
why that is a breach of the code so
yeah
yeah i mean i i don't think that alone
would be sufficient to find a breach of
the code um i think that
in this instance i considered it through
a breach of the gate because of
the the way that
the pub the publication was done in
terms of
it was done alongside derogatory
comments about council channel
councillor siddal please
thank you chairman
thank you mr rob nice to see you again
uh so in terms of the
uh complaint that counselor channel has
made i've got a a couple of questions
uh one of the things that i understand
in terms of the bullying
is
does the bullying have to occur
on council premises
and during council meetings
for it to be
an actual fact that there is bullying
taking place
no it doesn't um obviously there
are two elements to that the first is
uh is the conduct um
does the conduct fall within the the
jurisdiction of the kodai could the
council be said to be conducting council
business
um when um
the the behaviors take place now i think
members will be aware that obviously a
lot of their
a lot of the business that they conduct
as councillors is on council premises
absolutely there are times when they're
not on council premises or in council
meetings um when they're acting as
counsellors
and therefore the code um applies and if
the code applies then those elements
relating to bullying apply and i think
our definition of bullying um
demonstrates that it can certainly occur
outside of the chamber um and in
particular on social media
okay so the the crucial element there if
i can come back
is the fact that
councilor morris was talking to
councillor chana about council business
so therefore it does apply
that's correct okay
on uh 5.15
where we are talking about councillors
swain's complaint uh
into
the behavior during the virtual meeting
the use of the word corrupt the use of
the word corrupt on its own
you've interpreted that as as something
that's negative is that correct
that is correct yes and and
could you just
verify why that is to me
well
in my view the um the use of the word
corrupt is a suggestion that the it's
effectively questioning the integrity of
the officers um who are being named
at that part of the meeting it suggests
serious wrongdoing on their part
and therefore such you know such
accusations should be made seriously and
within the correct forum
not
um when they're being introduced during
a public part of a meeting
and a meeting that has no relation or
relevance to the accusations that
christie was making against them okay
thank you
uh
to come back again absolutely
uh so so the word itself is is a
negative word
uh but also we've got the additional
factor about how that word was said
so it was it wasn't stated it was
shouted
and it's and it's absolutely important
that members
are able to
express
genuine concerns about the conduct of
officers
as part of their role but it must be
done in an in the appropriate manner
in a manner that allows
firstly um for
the officers to um defend themselves
against any allegations and and also to
respect the the privacy of that process
while it takes place
this appears to have taken part at a
meeting where the officers had no
warning that the accusation was going to
be made it wasn't something that was on
the agenda it wasn't something they were
able to respond to because clearly
officers don't have the same platform
that counselors do during council
meetings um
to speak
um and so
there are a number of factors that would
lead to our considerations of as this
being disrespectful okay thank you mr
aaron thank you chairman thank you very
much
councillor perry
yeah
mr olum you you mentioned the code of
conduct of uh that applies to council
maurice have you got a copy of it that's
been signed by councillor morris
uh no i don't think i have got a copy of
it signed by councillor morris
why is that you you
you're using it for your your basis of
your evidence
surely the first you you would start
from the from the beginning
excuse me excuse me
you get the code of conduct with
councillor morris's signature on it that
would be your basis your starting point
obviously i'm not
a 300 pounder an hour lawyer
um i'm just muddling through and i've
been criticized already but surely you
can show me the code of conduct with
chrissy morrissey signatronic thank you
thank you i'm i'm i'm not a lawyer
either um or worth 300 pounds an hour
but but what i what i would say is that
um all councillors if they're to accept
office
um
do so um having to agree to abide by
their authority's code of conduct that's
clearly set out in the localism act and
therefore if chrissy has um accepted his
office as i understand he has
and if he continues to act as a
councillor which again i understand he
does then then he has a duty to abide by
the code of conduct
if you know it is and
to be fair to chrissy he's never
suggested otherwise to me
councillor perry
if he has if he doesn't so
you're saying it applies to him if he
doesn't even if he doesn't sign it why
has everyone else signed it then
uh councillor perry we haven't all
signed the code of conduct
hang on uh mr or mr orland if i gave you
a check and it didn't have a signature
on it
how difficult would that be
to uh cash but council prayer i think mr
auram has explained that when you take
office you automatically agree excuse me
ex agree to abide by the code of conduct
am i wrong mr turner
no that's that's correct it applies by
the operation of law
so previously the the under the
the people did sign the code of conduct
was passed as declaration of acceptance
of office but but nowadays no one is
asked to because it's not in the
prescribed form but it applies by virtue
of the law and you can see that in mr
lewin's report because the same point is
addressed there so it's it there's no
requirement for the code of conduct to
be signed okay okay
mr turner
obviously i'm the chairman of haybridge
parish council and chrissy didn't sign
my uh the code of conduct that we put
before him i
obviously asked the clerk to look into
this
and you know we've been researching the
new code of conduct that's coming out
etcetera
we've gone to on to all the clerks
forums we've asked all the questions and
there is no smoking gun i cannot see it
anywhere otherwise i would have made him
sign it
just for my peace of mind
i cannot i cannot see the smoking gun
that he has to sign this
and he doesn't need to sign it and if we
don't need to sign it
why is everyone else signing it
i have no idea whether anyone signs it
uh oh excess county council none of the
councillors have signed the code of
conduct because we don't ask them to i
there's
no there is no smoking there is no
smoking there is no smoking gun is what
you refer to basically the
the code applies by operation of law
because in the localism act
it appears to be you know some muddy
waters here and this is this is what
members are asked
what you're saying no for i i couldn't
find it i cannot find it anywhere
you can't find it because it isn't there
there is no requirement to sign the code
of conduct but the members
so
members are required members required
under the localism act to to abide by
the code of conduct
so why mr turner
are we asked to sign the code of conduct
if we do not need to
okay i think
when i when i became a counsellor i had
the code of conduct put in front of me
now i did my due diligence and i looked
into it the only thing i needed to sign
was an acceptance of office and there is
no requirement for the code of conduct
in the acceptance of office and if there
was that would be illegal because it
does not fulfill the elements of a
contract
you need to have stuff clearly stated in
a contract
now i had this discussion with paul
dodson
paul dodson told me that i must have
signed the code of conduct i asked him
to
show me the uh show me where i'd done it
because i knew i hadn't and he couldn't
show me he couldn't find it because i
didn't sign it now i'm happy to go
through this absolute charade
this absolute whitewash
because at the end of the day
i know that i have acted with integrity
and i can stand by all of my actions so
i'm happy to go through it but
councillor perry is rightly concerned
that you guys have got me down as being
signed up to the code when i simply
haven't
if i've signed the code show me
thank you councillor morris can i go to
councillor schemes please
when i joined multicouncil
and signed the office of acceptance i
was aware that that meant
that i was there for signing the code of
conduct
i didn't see a problem with that it
seemed perfectly sensible that we would
have a code of conduct i didn't have an
issue with it and uh had i had an issue
with it i would have raised it at that
point and when no doubt it would have
been explained to me well if you don't
sign if you object to the code of
contract do not sign this because you
won't be able to accept the office i
never had that conversation because i
naturally accepted the code of conduct
because meetings have to run reasonably
smoothly that's my interpretation of
what happened
councilor
um morris you very much council skanes
the thing is
you did so you didn't sign the code of
conduct or did you
acceptance of office which i knew
included the code of conduct
whereabouts in the acceptance of office
does it state that you're signing the
code
uh just through the chair i don't it
doesn't state it as i know i just kind
of i was aware of it i was aware that by
signing acceptance of office i will
therefore be accepting the code of
conduct it just it's not something that
i even questioned it just seemed so
obvious to me so can i just stop this
right here so
councilors you have not signed the code
of conduct is that correct no i haven't
missed the show thank you very much mr
turner could you please explain the
actual legal position and the rules on
which we are working on and this meeting
is based upon it so so the so the code
applies to all councillors
when that when they are counsellors
whether
there's no requirement for them to sign
the code of conduct or also agree or to
agree to it
so it's just i'm sorry i have a point of
order mr turner thank you mr morris
council mauricio
hello
point of order is
that why are we asked to sign a code of
conduct a code of conduct was put in
front of me to sign that i didn't sign
because i did not need to
the only thing we need to sign is an
acceptance of office
why are we asked to sign something that
we don't need to sign well councilmember
i was never asked to sign the code of
conduct in all honesty i really wasn't i
was i
perfectly accepted when i accepted the
office as counsellor that i would be
bound by the code of conduct
thank you mr chairman but the point
still is
that if you do not need to sign the code
of conduct why are we asked to sign the
code if
i can um
i can't answer directly in relation to
malden but i've certainly advised many
many local authorities on the code of
conduct and
my advice would always be that having
counselors trained on aspects of the
code and then specifically to sign up to
those to show that they've understood
them
whilst not a requirement is absolutely
good practice in making sure that their
counselors are aware of their duties
under the localism act so while it may
not be a requirement i would certainly
support it as good
practice
locally thank you mr
councillor perry
good practice
he's not has got nothing to do with
making someone sign it yes it's good
practice and for the record i signed the
code of conduct but
i didn't have to sign it and
what you're saying is good practice yeah
it is good practice councillor morris
hasn't signed it you can't produce it
you haven't been showing it he hasn't
he's just not signed it and i can't see
the link between what you're saying is
it applies to him if it doesn't if he
doesn't sign it if i was going to sell
you a house and i sent you a contract
and it wasn't psyched i think we fully
understand what you're saying thank you
thank you
thank you very much mr mitchell thank
you chairman just briefly
um there is no requirement to sign as
the monitoring officer says when you
become a counsellor the code applies the
key point you can't opt out of it and
there's no really it's academic as to
whether you decide or not the code is
there for you to comply with as a
council as a parish councillor as a
district councillor as county council
so it's uh it's there i'm afraid it
can't
you know it doesn't not you can't you
can't say that it doesn't apply to me i
haven't signed it it does apply to you
i'm afraid
thank you mr mitchell
councillor perry through the chair you
know you're saying it's there but show
me the
black and show me in black and white how
it applies if you don't sign it perhaps
i'll pay you with a check that i won't
sign because and see if you can catch it
show me i think it's been shown i think
it has been made quite clear that when
we all accepted office
we accepted the code of conduct
uh want one second please council morris
councillor siddall please
thank you chairman i know for a fact
that counselor morris has accepted the
code of conduct
because in 2019 he brought a complaint
against the current leader at that time
using the code of conduct so therefore
by using the code of conduct he has
applied or accepted
that he is agreeing to that code of
conduct otherwise he wouldn't have used
it himself in that situation we know
that when you become a counselor you
automatically accept the code of conduct
councillor morris has done that in 2019
by using the process and using the code
of contact
thank you very much councillor morris
thank you very much sherman um
councillor siddall the fact that um
people
that
the fact that other people uh have
accepted the code and therefore our
party to the code
is sorry
is um
immaterial to whether or not i have
actually signed up for it now
you're all saying that i've accepted the
code when i haven't is all i've done is
it is the
acceptance of office the
british law
does in fact state
that to accept a contract you need
agreement consideration capacity
certainty intention and legality
now nowhere in the um acceptance of
office
does it state that i've signed up to any
code
nowhere okay my contract the contract
would actually be void okay i am going
to stop the code of conduct signing or
not signing here and i'm going to say
that
i understand what you're saying
i think uh mr turner has presented um
morgan district councils and the
council's legal position so i'm now
going to say do you or would you like to
ask uh mr orem any questions in regards
to his report
yes please mr chair thank you councillor
morris alex how are you
good thank you chrissy how you doing
yeah not bad alex could you um tell me
um have you ever
um
apart from my case now
have you ever had
any instances at malden district council
of someone being called
cruella
in terms of sorry in other case work
yeah in morton district council
specifically uh
not that i can recall
did we not have a conversation mr oram
that at the start of your career
a conservative councillor
called a
member of staff throughout a whole
meeting cruella
yes but that wasn't at malden oh it
wasn't at maldonado okay i'm sorry about
that well that was it for apologies for
any confusion though that was that was a
different case at a different local
authority right so but it was a
counsellor
calling a member of staff cruella
several times throughout a meeting is
that correct that's correct yeah what
happened in that place
um the uh councillor was found to have
breached the code of conduct oh i
thought you said that uh it didn't go
anywhere
no i know in that particular case on the
council the daily mail reported on the
councillor's conduct
um the councillor was found to have
breached the code um and i believe was
suspended from office but i'd have to
double check
right okay there was a bit of a
miscommunication between the two um are
you aware of um
councillor thompson
having the name cruella do you having
the nickname corella deville for quite
some time
i'm not aware no no not we're at all no
worries thank you alex
no problem
would anyone like to ask any questions
of mr aurum
otherwise i should move on to mr
of course council morris
sorry alex i was just thinking about the
one um
so that's okay um
councillor boyce
i mean everyone was jumping up and down
and um you know
losing their absolute minds that i um
dared
um
say that councillor boyce
uh was too old um did councillor boyce
admit
that he had actually told me that he had
said to me that he was too old
um let me sorry let me my colleague mark
actually interviewed councillor voice um
so let me just refer to the report here
um but i mean i think
in terms of my own considerations i was
asked to look at what you said during
that standards committee meeting um and
i believe that the standards committee
in that regard didn't find you in breach
of the code anyway um
for saying it um that's my understanding
it's the truth that's why
it's a beautiful thing the truth and i'm
sorry that um i've got more bravery than
most other people when i
speak the truth and however ugly the
truth may be
it is the truth now i sat with
councillor boyce who
had
some
ability
to prevent the awful bullying culture
that was prevalent at this time at this
council
and councillor boyce
told me himself
i'm too old
i mean i think if members look at
paragraph
3.4.39 on page 32
there is councillor boyce's account
where he does acknowledge saying that to
chrissy
um
so all of the hoo-ha that i got from
members how dare you say that bob's too
old when he actually finally admits to
telling me he said i was too old so it's
all i've done is speak the truth
but i got barracked for it by everyone
i think i think
i mean i think members should know that
bob did actually say that he made it as
a sarcastic comment and not one that was
made seriously um
and and i can see why he was
subsequently upset by therefore by the
way it was represented but but to be
clear
it's not exactly that that we were
considering that was that was the
consideration at the stands committee on
the third of september
we were looking more at the way in which
you were able or you know defended your
comment chrissy and we felt that you
councillors should be given a wider
remit in what they say in those
circumstances and it was for that reason
that we didn't think on that occasion
you failed to treat others with respect
just for the record i'd just like to say
that i've never said the giza's lost his
marbles but there is definitely a hole
in the bag
thank you councillor morris i'm going to
go to councillor schemes please
yes i was interested in this part of the
report because i think it goes to a
fundamental problem i have said in the
past i'm too old for this it doesn't
actually mean i'm too old for it what it
means is i'm tired of it and uh can you
leave me alone about it or all sorts of
things or as indeed the explanation that
counselor
uh boys gave in that circumstance i
think one of the problems that we have
here is that chrissy
for often with good intentions
picks on a phrase such as a phrase in
councillor lagan's uh email
and turns into something that it is not
i don't think that uh now i wasn't there
so council
chrissy may be a better judge of it
uh though
council boyce was and he judges it
differently but i think there is a
tendency to pick up a phrase
that chrissy has and turn it into
something that is far more than it was
so when councillor boyce was saying i'm
too old what he means is i'm tired of
this and it doesn't mean to say he's
actually too old to do his job he's just
reached the end of his tether on that
particular thing at that particular
moment in that particular conversation
thank you councillor morris
on such an important issue
as
[Music]
bullying a criminal issue due to the um
hate crime and personal characteristic
involved in that bullying
if he has reached the end of his tether
on that
and being such an important thing he
isn't fit for the role
now
i would have much rather
fault that councillor boyce
was um
yeah too old and too disinterested
and mentally diminished to deal with it
rather than think that he was complicit
implicit
in it
and was allowing serious criminality to
occur on his watch and this is
indicative of how modern district
council
runs
because we allow nostalgia
and um
and
and kindness
to rule
this organization when what we need
are effective leaders
bob should not have been the chairman
someone that had more um more motivation
should have been the chairman but
because of his long service and because
it's a fluffy lovely old bob let's give
him a whole pass let's
allow
sub-standard people to be
in roles that should be filled by the
best now is all i've ever wanted for
this council in this community is for
the best people to be in the best roles
this is a far too important
organization with far too much money
running through it and vulnerable people
that need to be helped
for us to give out positions because
they've been
malden district council man and boy
there are inept officers and councillors
in roles
that should not be there
and we should be filling them with the
best people we can and we are not
because we've got this nostalgic modern
district council
we even said that the chief medical
officers
comments were perverse the other week no
one checked no one looked no one cares
two years running morton district
council have been deemed to have acted
unlawfully
this council acts unlawfully on a
regular basis
and no one seems to care and just for
the committee you will remember that
some time ago i was concerned about some
officers and i did ask that the
investigating and indisciplinary
committee was formed and i was
completely stonewalled
thank you thank you councillor morris
and council morris those are your
opinions which i appreciate and i
understand um i would just like to say
that uh
councillor bob boyce although he is an
elder gentleman has been a counsellor
for many many years and i've been to
many meetings with him
he's one of my uh he shares a ward with
me um and actually he has made some
incredible points he he knows the he
knows the council inside out he knows
the rules inside out which i don't
um so i i kind of concur with councillor
schemes i think the comment i'm too old
doesn't necessarily mean him saying you
know i'm
bonkers or i can't deal with this
what let me finish i think what it is
saying as counselor c says like like we
all do you know enough already
so
but i do understand that's your point of
view thank you councillor perry
what you're saying about bob boyce he
knows the system and he knows how to
play the system
exactly
thank you
any more questions please
so i would now counsel morris of you
are you happy with um
any questions to mr orrim
just to make sure
uh if you don't mind please chairman for
mr absolutely through the chair um mr
aurum
if um
if
the leader of the council the current
leader of the council
wendy stamp
had also referred to um
uh maddie thompson as cruella okay i'm
gonna would that be a breach
because this isn't about the leader of
the council i'm sorry i just can't let
that go on i'm sorry
no worries mr chairman what i'm trying
to uh i understand but like
you know
half this committee
has called cruella cruella
i i understand what you're saying yeah
so why am i here well because that's
your opinion i mean i personally
wouldn't call anybody cruella i never
have done i don't know if anybody else
has i don't think the leader of the
council has
again
as you're saying you're that that is
something you believe is her nickname
quite a few no i don't believe it's her
nickname i've been told it's her
nickname and it is her nickname thank
you and her conservative colleagues i i
gave it to her
and it is
and it has been council morris i don't
know that as her nickname i must admit a
nickname to me a nickname means that
somebody it's a name that we all use
in normally in a term of an endearment
to somebody who's a friend or something
like that or
i i've i've never known it so can i just
confirm as well then mr chairman
um
maddie thompson
in this very chamber during a democratic
vote referred to two members
as illegitimate children
but in the um swear word
now that is a fact she's admitted to
that she sat where mr turner is
and she called to
she called uh
two members
illegitimate
and nothing was done
nothing was done thank you very much how
can someone
how can someone complain i will accept
that point of order how can someone
complain
how can someone
complain do you have right other
questions she is being called a disney
cartoon villain
when she
uses explicit language
in the chamber and nothing is done
nothing is done you know i'll let you go
on but i must have a point of order and
i'm accepting the point of order so i
shall now ask again do you have any
other questions to ask mr orem
uh while you're deliberating could i
just ask does any other member have any
questions to ask mr orrin before we move
on
mr mitchell
just a a a very
detailed point regarding um councillor
boyce in your um
statement uh mr orem you you you argue
that uh there is no that he has not
preached
chrissy has not preached the code
um but in your summary you say that
every case in front of you there has
been a demonstration of bullying
behavior
um
does that cover the cancer the case with
regard to council of boys as well or is
that just the three cases
where you did find that there had been a
breach
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to um to clarify that and apologies for
any confusion no we we do not consider
that the bullying behavior relates to
the complaint by councillor voice
effectively we are finding that in
relation to the complaint from
councillor boyce
councillor i'm recommending that
councillor morris not be found in breach
of the code with regard that particular
complaint
but in regards to those the other
complaints we do believe that the
bullying is engaged and we set out
the specific behaviors that particularly
caused us concern
um in in the paragraph dealing with
bullying and just to
to um
to remind members that was found at
parrot
on page 48
publicly calling officers of the council
corrupt in an appropriate forum where
they had no right to reply
we believe in with a view of causing
them embarrassment and humiliation
and and those further bullet points as
we go down
thank you mr mitchell thank you mr uh
councillor morris please
thank you mr chairman um
mr auram um could you please tell me
councillor swain uh blesses cottons
he put a complaint in about me calling
corrupt officers corrupt
did he ever ask anyone can i just stop
you there councillor morris that is
purely your opinion
i never said it wasn't so well you've
just stated calling corrupt officers
corrupt i believe those officers
are corrupt i did then and i do now you
can't change my mind no no i will not
change my opinion
i
am thank you thank you what's not being
looked at
yeah i'm going to overrule that i'm
sorry um
sorry what are you overruling sir i'm
over council amaze i'm afraid
so what i would say is that that is your
opinion that is my opinion
and i will you have said
that that was the accusation is that
correct sorry the accusation you're
saying that councillor swain
has made a complaint that you called
corrupt officers corrupt is that correct
yes because
those officers i believe i believe are
corrupt i did then and i do now
so based on the fact that is purely your
opinion sorry mr chairman if you asked
an officer a direct question and they
lied to you
would you not
that is not corruption i believe that is
because that they have they have lied
they have lied to me okay
because so they can have an easier ride
in their job okay that is corrupt thank
you councilmember i'm going to go to
councillor
i was going to ask mr roon i was in the
middle of asking could i just go
we've got the evidence in front of us
council morris
and and you you're using you're
continuing
to use
the same language continuing to use the
things that are in this report
i i i yeah you know that i like your
contribution you know that i like some
yeah the things that you think about
however and i've said it to you lots and
lots of times
you do yourself a disservice and you're
doing it again
councillor morris
councillor siddal you are truly one of
the best counselors here i've always
said it
yeah there was three councillors that i
um rated
above all others
one of them um has shown a phenomenal
lack of integrity in my opinion
but you and councillor jarvis are the
best two councillors in this council
i won't take that away from you
now
i
am
just an ordinary guy trying to do my bit
and the reason
my language hasn't changed is because my
opinion hasn't changed and because what
i am saying i believe to be true
i am
f for foremost honest
now
i have
i can back up every single thing i've
ever said
with sound reason and if i'm ever wrong
i'll apologize you'll never hear an
insincere apology from me thank you
council morris going back to the
question i had for mr aurora uh i should
take that question thank you very much
mr chairman mr auram um
has
councillor swain
um
put the complaint in that i had called
them corrupt
do you know if if he took any steps
to actually find out whether or not what
i was saying was true
because as far as
i'm concerned
if i was councillor swain and councillor
swain had said
uh that the officers were corrupt
the first question i would have is why
have you said that
councillor swain hasn't ever asked me a
thing
i believe councillor swain has been put
up to this
complaint
and i've got
messages from councillor stamp that
confirm that
um
are you aware of of councillor swain
ever actually asking why i said it thank
you mr moore mr auram please
that didn't form part of my i mean my my
job effectively is to establish uh
whether councillor morris acted as
alleged
and then whether that conduct amounts to
a breach of the code in terms of a
counsellor or a person's reason for
making a complaint that tends to be
dealt with an assessment stage um and
would only be relevant if if it was
considered that the uh the counsellor
making the complaint was doing so
maliciously and without any um
reason without any uh
evidence of a potential breach of the
code um now
clearly um it would be difficult to
argue that this complaint was was was
completely without merit given that
we've established that the conduct did
happen
and that it doesn't matter or in my view
amounts to a failure to comply with the
code but
in terms of
any other reason counts for swain may
have where made the complaint or whether
he
he he conducted his own
uh investigation into the assertion made
uh by chrissie at the meeting i i'm
unaware
thank you
could i go to councillor schemes please
yes i think again we've got a situation
over
the use of words and interpretations of
words i've just heard from councillor
morris that he considers officers
corrupt if they lie to him
when people lie to me
i don't immediately think you're corrupt
i think why are you lying to me what's
the motivation behind it and even if i
discover that they've lied to me because
it makes their life easier that doesn't
lead me to use the word corrupt and i
can explain it very simply
when somebody alleges a public a a
member of the public of member of public
office is corrupt
that suggests to me
something extremely serious it suggests
to me that they could be on the take
that they could be lining their own nest
that there's backhanders and brown
envelopes happening somewhere it is an
incredibly serious accusation the truth
of the matter is is that in public life
and in private life people do mislead to
make their lives
easier i don't know what the facts are
in this case whether anybody did lie or
mislead
councillor morris it is possible that an
officer did because officers are humans
and most officers and most humans at
some stage rather may
twist the facts in order to make their
situation look better what i m my
concern is and i expressed it at a
public meeting when council morris made
this accusation out loud is that when
you accuse an officer of corruption that
is incredibly serious and in the public
mind uh suggests as indeed uh social
media that's covered this uh uh has has
also seemed to agree with that somehow
there is something fundamentally wrong
with the officer corps if you will at
this um
council it seems to me that the opposite
is true that generally we have an
officer
officers who are honest dedicated work
hard sometimes they trip up i have a
situation going on with officers now in
a personal in a project that i want to
get done well i'm not getting the
responses i want to hear i'm not getting
and i feel in fact that i might have
been misled but that would never lead me
to to announce these people are corrupt
because what i know the truth is is that
they're incredibly busy and the reason
why they're not getting back to me on
this thing that means so much to me is
because they've got so much else on so
i just feel you cannot throw around the
term corruption just because you feel
you've been misled just because you feel
you've been lied to and i think the
interpretation of words this example and
they can't the example of uh counselor
boyce saying that he just too old for
this and the council of lagon saying he
spoke for all the councillors it's
really important how we interpret words
and we need to give them more
flexibility than i think uh chrissy is
allowed for thank you council morris
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
um address councillor skins
um
i'll just read a verb quote
the jsc
has been proven corrupt and their
decisions cannot stand
and must be
reheard reheard
do you remember that councillor schemes
because that
is
that is an email from you on the 7th of
august last year so you are you are
throwing around in emails
as we and as we've all just found out
emails mean something because i've
called cruella cruella
in an email you have said that the jsc
that you are very that you are sitting
in you have said that that is corrupt so
could i just come back there council
morris i think we have all had um
historic problems and we all have
opinions and now
we are the new council we are all here
to hopefully rectify any of those things
which we think were slightly or
completely wrong
so i think again a private email to you
from councillor skins
is neither here nor there so then a
private email from me
to maddie thompson the other members is
neither here nor there so it needs to be
taken off
of my little charge list now then i
suppose you can't one way and the other
councilor schemes has called this
committee corrupt he's just spent five
minutes sitting there stating how the
word corrupt should not be used he's
used it about the committee that he is
sitting on and at the end of the day
guys we all agreed we should not be
investigating ourselves okay thank you
council morris councillor schemes
when i said that and i'd actually don't
remember it but i assume you're telling
me the truth so i'm not going to
question that i was probably
almost certainly at that time referring
to the previous committee that was found
by an independent report to have acted
improperly
what i'm saying is is that when you
stand up in the public arena of the
council and accuse officers of
corruption that is altogether different
what happened in the jsc situation was
that they were found to have acted
wrongly and and the the
corrupt yes probably poor use of words
for me but the bottom line is is they
acted wrongly and that's where i stand
so i shall allow you to come back on
this just one one more time counseling
i've got two sorry well then i'll let
you come back twice thank you very much
chairman um
councillor skains
acted improperly
we acted unlawfully
i agree
so we act unlawfully
what steps did we take
to ensure that we didn't act unlawfully
again i'm not finished mate to act
unlawfully again
there are
officers
that that hang on mate
there are officers
that have uh sat and watched awful
abuses and unlawful acts go on and said
nothing that's mine
taken into account maurice i've let you
come back thank you councillor i'll give
you the right to reply if you want to
i only just say that uh the situation
with the former gsc has been addressed
and the committee was reformed as a
direct response to their unlawful
behavior thank you councilman
okay i'm now going to i think we have
debated this report oh i still have
counselor perry thank you
sorry just very quickly i i mean
i would agree with councillor skins that
officers do things for an easy life we
came here early today and councillor
morris wanted to show me the layout what
i can do what i can't do
and we was we was meet greeted meeted
and greeted by some very hostile people
in here a guy called anton
who said that this room was booked from
11 30 and i said yes we know
thank you councillor perry thank you
thank you
hostile thank you
okay i'm going to move on to the next
report please um which is a report by
mr lewin please chair could i just
quickly correct of course you can uh
uh i don't believe that i just remember
what you said though there was a sort of
in a suggestion that i said that
officers do things for an easy life
i think what i was trying to stress was
that they are very busy and sometimes
they may be tempted like any other human
to do things to make life no and i am
going to stop it right there now please
sit down councillor perry i think we've
gone through this thank you council
maurice i'm going to move on i am
confident
no
comfort break please sir
oh come for break would we all agree to
a comfort break
yes indeed so shall we have how long
five minutes then please
so uh i shall join the meeting for five
minutes
it's five to two so we're back here at
two o'clock please
my
straight to uh mr lewin please for the
second report
thank you chair um so i was asked to
look at two complaints against
councillor morris
the first one was a collective complaint
submitted by the corporate leadership
team of the council on the 11th of june
and i've summarized that photograph too
and really it's about
what the clt described as a targeted
campaign
of sustained vindictive behavior and
they identified
one officer in particular who they
thought was on the receiving end of that
behavior
and the second complaint
was submitted by each member of the clt
individually that was a couple of days
after the first complaint and that
related to council morris's alleged
behavior at a committee meeting on the
10th of june
and they included a
link to a video
of that incident or part of that
incident which councilor morris had
posted on his facebook page
um
just to go through well in summary i
find that both of those
complaints were
well-founded and i uphold them
just to go through some of the detail in
the reports the first issue is about the
application of the code and you've
already heard quite a lot i'd say
perhaps too much
discussion about whether or not it
applies to councillor morris i'm not
going to add anything to that unless you
want me to
i've given you my very clear conclusion
in the report on that question
one issue that does arise i'm not sure
it was discussed earlier is about
councillor morris's activity on his
personal facebook page you'll have seen
in the report that i identified that he
has two pages and this this is quite
common and it might be
the case for some members in the room as
well
they have
i'm sorry we have a point of order
chancellor morris um
the gentleman is wrong
i have more than two facebook pages so
he's identified two of quite a few
he's got it wrong
thank you councillor morris
thank you chair as i said i identified
two pages um one of which counts in one
of which counselor morris explicitly
identifies himself as a counsellor now
um the facebook activity that's the
subject of uh the complaints was done on
a page where he doesn't explicitly
describe himself as a counselor at least
in the title but i concluded that
nonetheless the posts that i was asked
to look at and the video that i was
asked to look at was
published in an official capacity
because council morris is giving the
impression that he is acting uh as a
representative the council he's
commenting on council business he's
showing videos of himself on council
premises and he's in some cases posting
commentary about this investigation so i
was satisfied that
the material i was asked to look at was
within this of the code
i interviewed councillor morris in
person back in july
i also subsequently spoke with
councillor stamp and i spoke with
members of the clt
and
cheryl hughes the program's performance
and governance manager of the council
the
findings then the first i've i've
reported my findings under three
headings
um you'll notice the first two relate
directly to the complaints i was asked
to investigate i've included the third
heading his behavior during this
investigation because i think it is
not just relevant but i think it's
important for the jsc to consider this
so the first uh heading council morris's
behaviour towards sheryl hughes
identified a number of incidents over a
relatively short period of time as the
council was preparing to come back to
face-to-face meetings a difficult
difficult time for officers
for all sorts of reasons and members of
course as well
and
my conclusion is set out in paragraph 29
of the report
i agree with
what the clt
described in their complaint a clear
pattern of aggressive intimidating
behavior targeted at an individual
officer in an attempt to undermine and
humiliate her and i have no hesitation
in recommending to you that this is
bullying
and that it also brings counselor
morris's office into disrepute and
indeed because it was particularly
because it was done in a public setting
brings the council into distribute
the second heading is councillor
maurice's behaviour towards mr dodson so
this is at the
committee meeting the performance
governance audit committee meeting on
the 10th of june members might have
looked at the video for themselves and i
in my opinion it really speaks for
itself it's completely unacceptable
and my conclusion is summarized
in paragraph 35 of the report
again serious breach of the code
bullying brings council morris's office
and the council into distribute
the third heading
uh
relates to council morris's behavior
during this investigation as i said i
think it's important that the jsc
um takes this into account you're
obviously the body within the council
responsible uh not only for overseeing
um the code but i think in some to some
extent uh setting the culture within the
council and i think a councillor who as
i've set out in the report has shown
total disregard
uh and contempt for the code of conduct
process that ought to be considered by
the committee and findings made which is
why i've included it unusually
in my report
the final wish thing i wish to add it i
actually circulated a
slightly updated draft
to
officers so this draft this report is
dated
the 18th of july and on the 26th of july
sent an updated version that doesn't
look like that's made it into your
agenda i don't think that's a big
problem because i don't change any of my
factual findings but i do have
a short section on councillor morris's
freedom of speech which i should really
have included in my first in in the
version that's in the agenda
uh pac and it's an important issue and
it's one that the committee needs to
grapple with and it's it's also an issue
of mr orem's report as well and he's
given you guidance on it but i'll i'll
give you my two pence worth as well so
it's important to acknowledge that
council morris has a right of freedom of
expression and that's protected in law
and particularly expressions on
political issues or
matters of general public concern
attracts enhanced protection to the law
and there's very little in practice that
the code of conduct can do about that
kind of speech
now my opinion in my opinion we're not
dealing with political speech that
attracts that enhanced degree of
protection um we're dealing with
personal attacks on officers
now you'll be aware from mr orem's
report that there's an important
distinction between criticizing members
who are politicians they've voluntarily
entered public life and they're expected
to have a thicker skin and a greater
tolerance for chris
officers are not in that position they
are employees they aren't they don't
occupy such a public facing role
obviously
particularly senior officers the members
of your clt do but even so they are
entitled to some degree of protection
from this kind of behavior and in my
opinion councilor morris's um statements
cross
go well beyond the line of acceptable
speech that would be protected um by
well that would be protected by article
10
and therefore i'm satisfied um that
finding that council morris's behavior
breached the code would not
uh be a breach of his rights under
article 10. i hope that makes sense and
i'm sure mr turner can give you some
more advice on that if you need it so
that's my report so i'm happy to take
questions
thank you mr living
can you just make it very clear
yeah sorry i'm just going to make that
very clear that that was your report mr
lewin and the first report was mr orem's
report so that's just because no one's
picked it up on youtube so
um so the second report that we've just
had was a report by mr lewin thank you
very much thank you so now i shall ask a
councillor morris if he would like to
ask any questions of mr lewin i'd like
to ask questions after the rest of the
committee if you don't mind mrs
absolutely i shall now put that out to
the committee would anyone like to ask
some questions please
thank you uh councillor siddell
thank you chairman thank you mr learn
thank you very detailed report
in terms of behavior in in terms of
yeah
when someone
feels strongly about something
what's what would you
define as being passionate about
something and and then the behavior then
becomes bullying or intimidating
um
i would say that
it's absolutely fine and it should be
encouraged that counselors bring passion
to their job um it's really a question
of judgment and from what the
witnesses told me i don't think that
fashion is a fair description of
councillor morris's behavior here it
might have been initially
but
cheryl hughes in particular gave me
an account of
physically intimidating behavior
shouting
shouting her down
that's not passion in my view that's
aggression and
bullying behavior and if you've watched
the video of um
the committee meeting on the 10th of
june again it goes that's not passion
either that as i say in the report seems
to me to be a deliberate attempt to
ambush and humiliate mr dodson and it's
done in an aggressive way so it's
particularly because my report is really
looking at council morris's behavior
towards officers it's important for you
as a committee to remember to remember
and i'm sure you are well aware that
you're these are your employees and
they're entitled to a
uh a safe
workplace in which they are not subject
to uh unacceptable
behaviour excuse me point of order
safe at no point with anyone unsafe that
is
um
trying to paint a picture that i'm
dangerous
at no point was there any physical
aggression or is there any aggression
shown let alone physical aggression he's
trying to make it sound like i'm
dangerous and i'm not
thank you council morris i'm not sure
the use of the word safe actually
implies that i think it maybe means
comfortable environment or a workable
environment
then he should have used those words
he's a barrister he's a 300 pound an
hour vulture that should know how thank
you very much
to you
um thank you very much uh councillor
schemes
councillor siddall yes please you can
very quickly
so on on that question of safe that's
quite so i i'd like to explore that
um
yeah
it is
the perception of safe again that could
vary couldn't it mr lewin
yes and it's a quote it's a judgment for
you i've given you my
opinion in the in the report
that miss hughes in particular has been
subject to a lot of
stress
not only as a result of council morris's
behavior but because of the transition
back to face-to-face meetings that's put
a big burden on her team and counselor
morris has made her job extremely
difficult in doing that and in my
opinion that's unacceptable okay so and
the other the other crucial factor here
mr lewin is in many ways
we are the
the managers of officers we are the ones
that are setting the example for
officers
uh so do you think that makes this
particular more significant
um
yes i imagine um what my impression was
that
um lots of
officers are upset by council morrison's
behavior um miss hughes was the only one
i spoke to so i can't make any findings
about that was obviously spoke to mr
dodson as well but i think
my question was the officers are looking
for this committee to set an example
in the decision that they make on these
two complaints
okay thank you very much
councillor
uh i skeins as a foster carer among
other roles and as a foster carer i
learn
um
a lot about human behavior and
how people can behave who've come from
very difficult backgrounds i know for
example that uh
chrissy has had a difficult background
and one thing he hates more than
anything in conversations he's had with
me is bullying he cannot bear bullies
there's nothing that annoys him more
that gets him more upset and someone is
bullying i think the problem that
councillor morris is or that chrissy is
experiencing is that he doesn't know
when he's doing it he is not aware that
talking over somebody and shouting at
them and getting and not letting them
finish their sentence and getting more
and more angry and then throwing them to
the wolves of his social media and
watching them get
criticized and uh taken apart in social
media whether he doesn't think there's a
physical threat there is a feeling of
threat there is a feeling of
intimidation and i just don't think that
uh chrissy recognizes the power
that his approach has and indeed it is
intimidating i will confess
having agreed to take part in this
committee i did feel a sense of
intimidation i did feel well what
happens if by the end of this meeting i
have decided that actually chrissy has
made the wrong decision uh am i then
going to be thrown to his social media
walls how bad is that going to be that i
shouldn't be having those thoughts
so i am concerned that for all the
goodness in chrissy morris's heart in
his desire to do good sometimes in his
desire to do good he becomes over
passionate to the point of being abusive
and i do feel that yes unless i can be
convinced otherwise i think that that is
bullying behavior that is my concern
thank you councillor schemes
um chair if i could just pick up on two
points the council made
um the first one is i well i agree with
what the council has said you know to
the extent that those are within my
knowledge the first point is that
it seems a shame to me that council
morris lets himself get carried away
because often he does have a legitimate
criticism to make and i'll give you the
example of the
coveted secure measures that were
debated at your statutory at your
emergency meeting at the end of the day
this isn't on the agenda this isn't part
of the investigation
uh
if if you would like to call that as a
point of order i i still call that as a
point of order
okay thank you very much uh
my second point chair
is uh well to empathize with what the
council has said that i've given you a
description of a brief description in my
report of my experience of being in a
room with council morris and i did find
him intimidating and i got a little
flavor of what it must be like for the
two officers whose complaints i was
looking at um so
i'm in no doubt there's no doubt in my
mind that um
council morris's behavior is as i
described in the report
thank you
uh councillor perry
just to reply to councillor schemes and
mr lewin um
this shouting
surely the the word shouting
uh isn't just another trigger word it's
like offended intimidating it's one of
the words that people use when they want
to get their own way am i shouting now
or am i speaking loudly loudly to get my
point across
well council perry i think that's a a
match of opinion i feel that you are you
are
bearing your opinion a little too
harshly perhaps put it that way maybe
not shouting but maybe in my opinion
you're trying to put across something in
your example which i would find slightly
intimidating actually
how do you find me intimidating i'm
about
five five foot nothing so intimidating i
just think in your example where you
used a louder voice i found that
slightly intimidating
but the point i'm making is trigger
words and people when they want to get
their own way they use these trigger
words
to put people like councilman maurice
down i know and they say oh he's
shouting at me always offended at me
well nothing happens if you're offended
be offended you know you oh chrissy
morris offended me and next morning both
my legs fell off exactly
we are here and we are generally here as
councillors in meetings and in
committees to have debate and discussion
and i think there is a way that we all
behave and what is an acceptable way of
behavior and speaking to one another and
i think if one member starts shouting
which is not not a key word it's a
descriptive word it's actually what
happened if one member is shouting then
the other member perhaps
will find that intimidating intimidating
the point i'm making is where does
shouting start
and where does raising your voice and
getting your point across end it's again
it's another one of these gray areas
that we're we're tasked with debating
now and depending on which side of the
fence you see it
councillor morris is intimidating and
shouting and bullying or he's getting
his point across we are counsellors we
need to get our point across
and um you know chrissy morris
asked mr lewin how much he was getting
paid
to get his point across he didn't answer
perhaps he'd like to answer now i don't
how much of taxpayers money
is a question i'm not putting and
thank you mr thank you please sit down
thank you
as i say we've i think we've discussed
the word shouting and i'm going to go to
councillor siddal actually
thank you chairman
i think the crucial element here
is the dynamics in the relationships so
if i'm a member
and councillor morris talks to me
strongly i can talk strongly back to him
but in terms of this particular
situation and these this particular
report
it's
a member
with an officer now if i shout at an
officer
it's very very difficult
for that officer to shout back at me
they're not in that position to do so
and that's the clear distinction with
this particular report it's not about
member to member we can have robust
conversations we can have robust things
we should still show respect however in
this situation and in these examples and
in these cases and it also applies to
the investigation it is really really
it's virtually impossible
for an officer
to shout back
and it's inappropriate so therefore
that's the crucial difference between
this report on the previous one we are
in this particular one talking about
council morris's behavior towards
officers and also
to the investigator
thank you and i should go to mr mitchell
please
thank you chairman good afternoon mr
lewin um
just a
basic question really you've got a lot
of experience of these kinds of
investigations have you ever come across
a case where the entire council's
corporate management team has made a
complaint to the standards committee
that you've had to investigate thank you
that's straightforward thank you very
much i mean does that indicate anything
to you about the seriousness of this
complaint
um well yes obviously it does i've never
seen that happen before obviously take
the uh complaint
consider the complaint on its merits but
yes i think that is probably an
indication of its seriousness
council morris
um i've just to reply to um the
independent person that just shows the
complicity in this council of
corruptness that is taking place um it's
professional courtesy they've all got
together and they've all gone you know
what chrissy morris is trying to expose
us for
the
corrupt and inept
officers that we are
let's get him because up until now it's
just been off um it's been members
going at members
what i have noticed that over the course
of many years
certain officers not all and i would
like to take this opportunity
to state that there are some brilliant
officers at morton district council
thank you councillor morris sorry thank
you for that that's all right that's
right you know um credit where credit's
due we've got some excellent officers
but we also have
some corrupt some lazy and some inept
officers
okay and
and
i have to stop you there councillor
morrison
i'm sorry but i i i'm really not going
to let you do this so let me do what you
don't know what i'm going to do do you
then chairman do you have something
relevant to say to the request yes i do
i've got plenty
okay well then
can i just before we do that i would
just like to clarify okay
are there any more questions from any
members to mr lewin and then i'll come
back to you councillor morris
okay so council morris would you now
like to
make any comments on either of the
reports
please i still have questions for mr
lewin
then i'll allow you to answer that
question ask that question i'm sorry so
um can you please tell me
what was the purpose of the telephone
call to sheryl hughes
um she was a witness in one of the
complaints so i thought it was important
to speak to her
now can you please tell me what was the
the purpose of the telephone call
from myself
to cheryl hughes
well as i recall you were uh
wanting to challenge some of the
covert secure measures that have been
proposed in her report
i had a couple of problems with the
report can you tell me what those
problems were please
um
uh i believe council morris is coming to
a point i am is that
i'm just pointing out that this guy
comes in
does a few hours at 300 quid an hour
um and and basically doesn't know
anything about what's actually happened
so going back to the question mr lewin
what were the points that i wish to
discuss with the author of the report
because on the bottom of the report it
did say any queries inquiries contact
cheryl hughes didn't it
so
it wasn't me singling out cheryl hughes
it was me
ringing the person that had put the
report together because it had a couple
of glowing errors in it didn't it but i
i think council mice the fact is we're
not really discussing the actual
conversation or why you why you made the
telephone conversation it is your
behavior towards
uh my disputed behavior mr chairman yes
to understand why the telephone this all
revolves around the telephone
conversation i know but the telephone we
need to we need to have the meat and the
bones of the telephone conversation it's
a simple question so i kind of got an
answer by now it isn't really though
it's it's about it's about the way you
ask those questions isn't it
no it's not about if that is disputed
at no point does cheryl hughes say that
i threatened her that i swore at her if
i'm not allowed
to ask
questions of officers when they get
important parts of the report wrong now
mr chairman we're we are getting
sidetracked and this is taking up
valuable time so i simply would like to
know mr lewin
why was i ringing cheryl hughes
you were ringing to talk about the
proposal in her report that members
might be required to wear masks at
in-person meetings and they might be
asked to take lateral flow tests before
turning up to council premises
wrong and right
how you did it
wrong and right
the first issue i had
was that we as a council were going to
promote
discrimination
by asking someone that cannot wear a
mask why they are wearing a mask
that is discrimination i think we did
agree on that
that to ask someone that's not wearing a
mask why they are not wearing a mask
that would be discrimination is that
correct
i've made it clear in my report
could you just answer the question
please he's trying to council morris so
as you have been allowed to speak please
allow mr lewin to speak
please thank you members should be
entitled to raise these kinds of
challenges but the issue for me is how
you did it councilor morris and i think
you did it in an inappropriate way
considering that you did you wasn't
privy to the conversation and that you
have been paid by this council your
hatchet man that's been paid by this
council
to find that
okay is is quite um absurd okay so thank
you thank you councilman what was the
other i did i haven't got the answer to
the question i've asked well i would
just at this moment now like to go to
councillor fleming and then i will come
back thank you
thank you chair um i just wanted to so
from what councilor morris is saying he
is disputing uh
the telephone call he's disputing that
uh he was irate and unaggressive so i
wondered whether councilor morris had
recorded that telephone call
as he
has a habit of doing
because that would actually
provide evidence would it not did you
record it thank you
council morris no i didn't recall it i
um i i have a call recorder on my phone
that records pretty much every call that
comes in because obviously i never know
what cranks are going to call me
that call was done over teams and
if i have an inkling a telephone
conversation may go wrong then i
sometimes recalled it as i did with um
penny channel because i was pretty
certain that she would make some um
false claims so if i believe that i need
to
then i will recall
because it's in everyone's interests and
my own safety but it was over teams so i
didn't recall it counselor fleming
uh so if it was over teams set up by uh
miss hughes what was it was the call
recorded
was it you know was was that team's
meeting recorded thank you
i don't know that i'm afraid council
morris
i'm not too sure i don't know i'm good
on social media but i'm not a good tech
person at all
the the way i understand it was that um
people
at morton district council is a lot
easier just to teams call someone so i
do
i did teams call quite a bit now i get
up early and i do a lot early
and
at nine o'clock which i see is the start
of the working day i thought i would
ring sheryl hughes because she got a
couple of absolute whoppers wrong in
that report that would have embarrassed
this council and i wanted to speak to
her because at the bottom of the report
it says anyone got any queries speak to
sheryl hughes so i did i run her at 9 00
am and i know when i'm talking to
someone that's just been woke up and
doesn't appreciate the call she admits
in her statement where she can't spell
the word paddle
that
she
didn't have the best of phone calls so
what with her believing that i'm being
condescending when i'm trying to explain
to her how she's going to drop this
council in hot water and have us act
unlawfully again
sorry unlawfully again
that is why i phoned and i actually did
say to her and i believe she actually um
has confirmed that i said to her i'd
rather sort this out
privately where it causes no
embarrassment to the council
than in committee
where it's going to be blown open as it
was
rather than take my concerns
into account
she decides to run off to clt and see lt
get all rubby handed and go oh this is
our opportunity to try and shut chrissy
morris up it's very very funny
that
the only time
clt put a complaint in
against a member against a councillor is
when that councillor
is exposing their lack of action their
ineptitude and their corruption
thank you councilman's counselor perry
i'd just like to point out that
mr lewin hasn't answered my two
questions yet thank you thank you
council skins
i think one of the problems here
is that uh chris he doesn't really
understand the impact of
of
his approach on people of how
debilitating it can be of how it can
keep them up at night how they can how
these serious accusations how
the
behavior that i see as aggressive and he
does not see as aggressive can really
impact people's desire even to continue
working in the job that they're in i i
understand though i cannot present
evidence that this has had quite a
debilitating uh effect upon officers as
indeed it has upon
counsellors who come under his uh
extreme passion i am as much as i
support uh chrissy in many ways i do
have serious problems with the way in
which he he
uses
um
language and volume and tone
uh to get his point across
that is my major concern here
thank you councillor skeens
councillor siddal
thank you chairman
again it goes back to that factor of
how someone perceives
the way that someone else is behaving
and
because you just use the term
that cheryl hughes
ran off
to clt
to talk about it that implies
that that person
did feel in some way
that they were unnerved by that
situation or they don't feel comfortable
a situation if an employee goes to see
their manager
it's because they're feeling
uncertain in that situation
so you've described there the reason why
cheryl did it
because she felt unnerved after she had
that call with you after she had that
call she felt unsettled and she felt
that she had to go and speak to her
managers about it because of that
counselor morris
she ran off
because she got caught out mate
that's that's the
the end of the day she put in a report
that people that weren't wearing masks
should be publicly shamed
that is discrimination and i've i've
sought legal advice on that it is
discrimination we don't if if someone if
someone in a wheelchair came into this
meeting right now we would not be asking
them why they can't walk
yeah we should not be shaming people
with disabilities in public meetings
that is discrimination and richard i
think the worldia but
you know i've got a disability um
discrimination specialist that has
confirmed that i think even mr mr
whatever his name and paul turner two
legal people here would confirm that and
the very fact that we did not
ever
use that
shows that perhaps we were wrong because
i had to get sent into this council a
letter before action
yeah to just to prevent that happening
the second part
was that
stating that trying to coerce and force
us
into doing a medical procedure
without our consent we were we were
being threatened with rule 10 which is
disorderly conduct
to do a medical procedure that needs our
consent that is also wrong
that it is wrong on so many levels now
those two parts of the report worried me
because they would have yet again
caused this council to have acted
unlawfully now i brought it up with the
offer as the bottom of the report said i
didn't choose cheryl hughes
she done the report i wrung her
she was tired
she was ratty
she basically did she
the professional way of doing it is
saying thank you for bringing that to
our attention councillor morris i'll
bring this up with whoever the line
manager was dodson holmes and then get
them to ring me
she did not need to manipulate
and engineer
any ill feeling between the two of us
she previously sent me an email
complaining that i had ruined a meeting
because of the homophobic bullying that
was going on in this council she doesn't
like me and i'm not particularly keen on
her
now
this has been
manipulated
to ensure that they've got something to
throw at me here i mean
using
using someone's nickname
saying someone is old when they've told
you they're old
yeah ringing someone up and
basically complaining
that
there's two things on an agenda oh it's
so naughty
i've not sworn i've not threatened i
didn't shout
yeah i was condescending
so was she and i think she admits that
on her report at the end of the day guys
you're setting a very very um
bad president if you decide that i've
breached because from that moment on you
might as well just not ever speak to any
officers and and it going to be funny if
you guys find me to have breached
anyone that then goes for an employment
tribunal you ain't got a chance have you
you know and it'll cost the taxpayers
loads more thank you councilman
uh mr lewin um has chrissy ever
mentioned any of this before
um we did have a discussion about the
appropriateness of some of those secure
measures um in our meeting
but obviously that's not a question for
me to offer an opinion on i was more
interested as you sheriff identified
with how he brought those challenges up
and whether he'd done that in an
appropriate way
thank you
okay so i'm going to ask again does
council morris sorry so one one more
question i'd just like to ask the uh
esteemed barrister hatchet man um
how much did uh you cost the morton
district council taxpayer an hour please
uh that's not relevant councilman i'm
sorry it is relevant it
very much is the platform sir
because this platform
the public can see the public have a
right to know
where their council
we had serious criminality go on at this
council previously
no barrister was was was asked
to ask mr lewin to answer that question
i'm sorry well i'd like to mr mr lewin
mr
has a freedom of speech absolutely do
not tell him what to say so i fully
agree with you councilman thank you and
if so mr lewin
how much money did you cost the morton
district council taxpayers considering
we've got food banks that need help
thank you but don't get help in this
district
but we've got 300 quid to give you an
hour so council mice i'll allow you to
answer that question of of mr lewin and
if miss losing says no comment then i
think that will be the end of that i'm
afraid
um i've been over this a lot with
council morrison i'm not going to answer
the question thank you
vulture councillor scheme vulture sorry
thank you council schemes uh i'd like to
ask councillor morris a question did he
object to the money paid in the previous
uh investigation uh at the jic
that found that the previous gsc was in
breach of the law did he object to the
costs of that thank you council morris
would you like to answer that or not
sorry so councillor skanes did i object
to the
money spent in the previous
no i didn't because um i saw it as
reasonable
um there is
at the end of the day i'm here for the
talking yeah no one
has to um worry about me not turning up
to defend myself at jsc like fluka
didn't
no one i'll talk to anyone about this
because it is an important issue and it
is a serious issue thank you thank you
council morris the the fact that we've
got a barrister in
at 300 pound an hour when we've got
people starving in our district is
ridiculous i can understand the
investigator i can understand the
monitoring officer i am now going to be
not a 300
embarrassing teacher and the next part
of this procedure council morris is i'm
going to ask you if and invite you
if you would like to make any
representation with respect to the
conclusions of the reports so we've
asked questions so now this is an
opportunity to comment on the conclusion
of the reports
thank you mr chairman um quite simply
i have grave concerns and have had grave
concerns
um as members know and can confirm i
have tried to
get these concerns
investigated and addressed
and
literally i can't no one will listen
now there is an element of double
standards
and hypocrisy to all of this
because
as
you guys all know
the leader of the council
has herself
i'm gonna have to be
guilty
of doing exactly what i'm here today do
you have any other comments
to make in respect to these yeah we've
got a few we've got a few okay richard
holmes paul dodson and simon quelch
have all
watched and done nothing but this is not
awesome this is sir i'm getting there
i'm getting there councilman please i'm
just saying you know this is your
opportunity to
to give some sort of conclusion to
and i'm trying the reports themselves
and i'm trying to let this go off into
some i'm not gonna okay well then i
shall let you continue thank you very
much sir um
richard holmes paul dodson
and simon quelch
have all
have all sat and watched while serious
criminality has occurred on several
occasions
on several occasions and they have done
nothing they knew what was going on and
they did absolutely
nothing
they are inept and in some cases corrupt
they have lied to me
and mark hurd
and the whole council
and they have covered up
corruptness
criminality
hate crimes okay threats
and financial improprieties okay you've
you've said you've said it i'm glad you
have you wanted to do this you wanted to
say this and and you've said what you
wanted to say so i now would like to
move on so
if you have any other comments in
regards to the reports please
uh
councillor perry yeah obviously i'm not
quite sure what i'm doing because i'm
uh very unprofessional but i just i just
i thought this was like a trial so i've
just got a few summoners this isn't the
trump no but i i thought it was and
that's why we came in here well this is
a joint standards committee
the summit
well
judge and jury
yeah obviously i understand it's not a
trial because people work with chrissy
so um
so summing up am i permitted to just sum
up you i shall give you that opportunity
thank you i just made a few notes here
um
with my other hat on at
um
haybird parish council i've written
we've we have resolved
to write
to
head of paid services it was it um paul
dodson about our concerns but i just i'm
sorry this is in regard to the
conclusion of the reports
yeah that's what i've invited you to
comment on
reports i'm sorry isn't this isn't this
isn't a soapbox moment this is to i've
invited you to make comment on the
reports
so if
that i'm willing to let you do
so do you have any comments to make to
the conclusion of the reports the
reports seem to be connived right and
people have got together and this is
what happens when you get employees they
all get together or people sit there in
the canteen and so he said this he said
that and like i say there's these
trigger words shouting
is he shouting and robustly question
aggressive or is someone we as
counselors
should be questioning everything i
question everything i'm sure you do too
sir so are we questioning the reports
are you saying that you disagree with
the reports
yes
thank you yeah we disagree with the
reports and it it looks to me that
they've all got together that's fair
comment if you disagree with the reports
i can accept that
and you know no one's defined that
there's a there's a lie there that a
line there between bullying
and robust questioning no one's proved
this to me today
you know chris is a bloody good
counselor in haybridge he's the deputy
chair
and you know
to give you an example me myself chrissy
and councillor lewis
are all completely opposites
politically
and we have jovial
activities to get things done councillor
perry i'm not questioning your your
ability or or
or how good a counselor you are and i
agree with you you are good counsellors
so i shall now ask you
i haven't quite finished
um
you know you're going about the reports
but the accusers are not sitting here
why no but this as we say this isn't
this isn't a court of law people have
made complaints
not necessarily well i don't know i'm
sorry i'm i'm not a lawyer or a
solicitor i'm just a chairman of this
committee so i'm giving you the
opportunity council morris um can i just
ask mr turner who is legally trained
then you me um
mr turner in a court of law
if a witness
or accuser
didn't show to be cross-examined
what would happen terry would you sit
down please thank you
so it would depend on it would depend on
the circumstances but this is this is
about the consideration of
um the reports and you've been given the
opportunity to raise any disputes about
the um reports months ago and you've
chosen not to do that so we so possibly
is
so there's no reason what why the
committee cannot make a finding based on
the reports and based on what you've
told them today
um i didn't choose not to do so uh you
are unaware of the circumstances which
i'm not entitled to give you um i did
ask you if this was a court of law and
someone didn't show
what would happen
so it depends so depending on there are
many different types of course of law
but most most courts of law have
processes which allow written evidence
to be considered
so
if so are you saying
that
a cross-examination i have a point of
order council morris
we're now discussing the joint standards
process rather than what's before
um and the joint standards process was
just updated a a week or so a couple of
weeks or so ago
and the joint standard process says that
witnesses do not and people who give
evidence do not need to be here the only
person who needs to be here and that's
optional is yourself counselor maurice
and you are now got you've now got an
opportunity to put your point of view
you are not putting your point of view
you are discussing the joint standards
committee process so can you please put
your point of view
i'll say what i want councillors at all
it's uh it's not for you to tell me what
i need to come across i would like to
put across
that
i have not had the common law right the
confrontation clause i believe that uh
it goes to mr turner will probably be
able to uh advise us further than that
not a single one of my accusers has been
here to answer a question i mean county
um
let's go to the to the end of the
reports then
councillor swain's report has no basis
whatsoever because he has
put a complaint in purely on um
his perception without knowledge
he did not and has not asked me why i
thought the clt were corrupt
now the first thing that he should be
doing when he hears a counsellor say
that an officer is corrupt is finding
out why to see if there's any meat to
the bones he didn't do that he just put
it in he put that in wendy's stamp has
told me that he's put that in because
the conservatives asked him to
okay so and
the um that i i stand by my um
affirmation that um those officers are
corrupt because they've lied and they
have sat there counseling and watched
serious bullying and done nothing thank
you you have said this before and and
i'll say it again so and i will continue
to say it thank you until i am listened
to and something is done can i now we
cannot have officers lying to members
and officers watching people get almost
um
bullied to death please thank you i'll
move on thank you the second can i hold
you a second and just again can i go to
councillor bill please who hasn't
actually had a chance to speak thank you
i know i haven't said much but i've just
been listening and
this is just sickening
you've just accused
the conservatives
of getting an independent
timon
that's rubbish as we now you wait and
listen now thank you
now thank you basically
you've also turned round
um and totally disrespected the chairman
okay
at the end of the day you just keep
coming back for a confrontation you've
basically dug your own hole here today
you've continued doing exactly what
you've been accused of
and councillor siddall is right
we are the the managers as such
of our staff and if the staff feel that
they've been intimidated
to the point that you're
you know you know turning up for
meetings an hour or so early
you know
the offices and whatever
have actually got other meetings you
don't know that that that room was
booked before then but you've basically
proved beyond a shadow of a doubt to
anyone here today
the reason why you're here
you've dug your own hole chrissy
you really really have
thank you and i said at the end of the
day all you do is keep
contradicting everything that people are
saying
okay council bill thank you very much
councillor morris
councillor bill you've just had to guide
me for turning up to meetings early at
least i'll go to meetings okay at least
again you're holding on on on a minute
here i might well be but it's a very
important thing
doesn't put right how many times in ten
years has council of bill thank you
councillor morris this this is this is
not a
please both of you and i like colton
councillor i love i love holes
thank you please okay so what i would
like to do now is ask mr lewin or mr
omran if they have any questions to ask
of you is that okay
so mr lewin can i ask you first do you
have anything that you would like to ask
of councillor morris thank you chair no
questions from me mr arum do you have
any questions that you would like to ask
of councillor morris
uh no no questions from me thank you
chair thank you let's get to morris one
second members and uh mr mitchell do you
have any questions that you would like
to ask of councillor morris please
ah councillor siddal sorry i'm drifting
away
chrissy
do you
accept
at all
that at any point
you might have behaved inappropriately
i
haven't acted inappropriately i might
have acted robustly i might be stubborn
um i might be forthright but i haven't
acted inappropriately
believe me
i
i've got a gob on me if i want to act
inappropriately
i mean inappropriate is what may happen
in the future
not what has happened in the past
councillor
cousy
do you regret
anything that you've done
over the last 18 months or so
i regret that i haven't been more honest
and told people um the uh
actually what i think more
thank you uh mr mitchell can i ask you
please do you have any questions uh yeah
transit baptism of far from there chris
um
[Music]
just this really i mean the last time
you had an outing here
in front of this committee was about a
year ago as far as i understand
um and so i looked at
looked at the uh
video of that um and
councillor jarvis i think it was had
made quite a long and eloquent statement
on your behalf
obviously had an outcome that was to
your satisfaction because the committee
was comfortable with uh your behavior up
to that point i've noticed that two of
these complaints actually predate that
meeting one of them's about what
happened to that meeting when the others
happened afterwards i mean after that
meeting
chrissy did you change your behavior did
you change your approach in the light of
what council jobs and other members had
said i'm just interested how you how
many you may reacted to that
um when i first got to this council sir
uh i sat
in that corner seat over there um very
quietly i didn't say a thing for six
months
i sponged in what this council was about
i came to every meeting
i wasn't on any committees but i came to
every meeting and i watched the dynamics
of the people in the room
i bothered to find out what was going on
and
ask questions
you know
subtly and quietly and after six months
i noticed what i thought needed to be
changed about this council
um
it was a it was a pre-prepared plan i i
said right six months you've got your l
plates on
you watch you see what you think needs
to be improved and and then you spend
six months trying to do that in the
correct manner
which is exactly what i did and then
after the year
when
nothing was happening whilst the
bullying and the criminality was still
happening almost everyone was busy
looking at something else and not
actually noticing what the elephant in
the room was that is when i decided to
change my tactics
because the correct procedures weren't
working and obviously had never worked
because there's been a bullying culture
at this council for many many years and
it's been a serious one
so um
[Music]
for wanting to change things for the
better and believe it or not i do
believe things have changed for the
better because this council has gone
from
a
very
dark and um
completely bullying culture
to a more open culture where
more people are speaking and
it's got slightly better
but after the meeting that you spoke
about um and
after the conversation i had a very long
conversation with carl jarvis who i hold
in the highest respect
that conversation i believe involved
richard siddall a little bit and then
there was also
wendy stamp in that conversation and we
all agreed and i do have messages
confirming this to do our best
now
we've got in the independent group got
in
and it hasn't done its best it's just
looked to do a little bit better than
the conservatives
the main problem that this council has
which i want um addressed
is that it's a bit like yes prime
minister
the politicians think they're in charge
but really the officers are in charge
and they choose
what they do
even after the councillors make a
resolution
and as a for instance my friend here he
hasn't he had an erection problem
this
sorry well yeah the flagpole is an
erection
um
the flagpole
that richard had
um was completely legal i know this for
a fact because i'd helped other people
out with similar problems
this council found the resources to go
and photograph my friend's erection
to
put reports in
um and to to send letters out
but we did not after after making a
resolution on the 18th of march
have the office of power
to
phone up a food bank and ask them what
they needed even though we'd made a
resolution that we was going to do that
we did not have the officers
to look into
not sending
um
uh bailiffs to vulnerable people as the
law i'm pretty gonna have to do
counseling
sorry sorry please yes thank you
so sorry sir um the the the cut and
thrust of it was
that um now that the independent group
was in
that um it would change
um and sadly it hasn't
and i have pages and pages and pages
of stuff where i'm talking to the leader
of the council
that confirms this and that is why i
have become
um
belligerent great occasion i have a
technical issue councilman so i'm going
to stop you there the television is
about to turn itself off so
and it says uh tv will turn off and it
has
it's gone automatically it's turned off
so
uh would you mind turning on the
television again thank you
all right
mr chairman can i just take this
opportunity to request that we have a
recorded vote please
i might not be but i'm just asking
anyway you cannot do that sorry
we're not streaming at the moment so it
would if everyone like to wait a second
oh we are streaming oh so we can carry
on so
councillor schemes
um i'm just going back to something i
think i heard you say uh chrissy and i'm
wondering if you can confirm am i right
in thinking that you said a few minutes
ago that you do not think that you have
behaved inappropriately at this council
in the past but that may be something
that happens in the future and if you
did say that is that some form of threat
to the council
can we just hold on a second we are not
streaming apparently
we are streaming
so can we just can we just hang on a
second please and get some some older
here so councillor schemes would you
like to re-ask your question because we
were not streaming but we are now thank
you yes am i rightly thinking that you
said a few minutes ago that you do not
think you have behaved inappropriately
this council in the past but that may be
something that happens in the future and
if you did say that is that a threat to
council of officers
it's not a threat to council and
officers what i'm trying to say
councillor schemes i might have been
that i should have said maybe a little
bit more eloquently is that up until
this point for the whole time that i've
been at this council i've actually sat
in my hands a bit and i've not been as
honest and as forthright as i wish i had
have been right
and that is what may change after this
thank you councilman we accept your
explanation um
oh councillor fleming sorry
thank you chair just before we sort of
wrap up i was interested to ask
councillor morris what was it
that motivated him to become a counselor
was it was sort of one event or
i'm interested to know whether he
he decided to become a counsellor to
sort of mix things up to get you know
what was was that the intention to to go
in there and
shake it up was that the intention thank
you
uh councillor fleming you have this ugly
lug to blame for me uh entering the
political scene
um i spent many many years
with no uh political office uh behind me
helping people out with various problems
a lot of the problems did come back to
the local councils
and rather than
deal with um
singular cases
on a one-to-one basis i thought that
it would be
interesting to see
exactly if i could um
help from from the the point of
counsellor
more people than just the um the odd
people that were coming to me
[Music]
my motivation for uh stepping up as a
counsellor was that
everyone complains and no one tries to
do and i'm a doer
yeah up until my recent illness i had
100
attendance record even though i wasn't
on a single committee
as everyone would here would know
i sit in attendance to every meeting i
take my i take this role very very
seriously
and rather than be one of those people
that complains without actually trying
to help and trying to change
i thought i'd step forward and see if i
could make a change and if i could
encourage
other people
to make a change because the way i saw
it and the way that i correctly saw it
was a lot of counsellors
get in with loads of promises and once
they're in they put their feet up on the
on the coffee table and take all the
kudos of being called
um
counsellor
um and i wanted to be a um a fresh
um people's person counselor which i
think i've been
and
make
make a difference
and
not be one of those people that just
sits back behind a computer screen and
whinges but actually tries to make a
difference thank you councillor morris
councillor bill
thank you chairman
um i don't know which way to say this
basically councilor morris was taken on
as an independent member
and initially i think he did have the
support with the independence
but through his
behavior i think and the way he puts
things across he's definitely passionate
i'll give him that and i've got a lot of
time for him
i'm a bit of a rebel myself a silent one
but chris is a bit louder than me but at
the end of the day
what i can't understand is he wants to
do so much for
people
of molten district because that's who we
all represent although we've got our own
individual wards
but he started off as an independent
then he started picking on the
independence after he finished with the
conservatives
and i don't understand how he
doesn't sort the take on board that to
get things done
you need more than one person out of 31
people
in a group
and unfortunately
there's not people
are backing him
because of the unfortunately the
aggressive way he comes across but
that's down to his passion i understand
that
but it's he really
needs to get more people on his side
to actually get something done
that's what's frustrating and i can see
where
counselor morris's
frustration comes from it is frustrating
one person against the other 30 is never
going to work ever
he needs to get people on board with him
to get the things done that he wants to
do and he has got some good projects
okay thank you council bill councillor
siddal please
wait one sec i will let you come back of
course
one second though please
thank you council morris
thank you councillor bill um councillor
bill i didn't uh
start on the conservatives then go to
the independence i've just literally
taken on
whatever i saw that i thought was wrong
and um
as everyone knows i've had many fallouts
with many different councillors and the
reason i've had those fallouts is
because i don't agree with some of the
stuff they are doing have said or
whatever
um
i i can put all of that behind me
for instance i'm not a fan of councillor
heard
after he backed the officers that lied
to us
but i still voted for him to be to be
chairman
and
you know in talks with wendy stamp um i
put across that i put my personal
feelings aside so i'll put my personal
feelings aside
for um the the community and the greater
good
uh it's just that i'm not prepared to
sit and listen to the lies and twaddle
that come out of this council okay thank
you councillor morris thank you can i go
to council please and this may i just
say i think we we've gone round this
enough so i'm going to make this the
last question unless it's something
that actually council morris really
feels compelled that he needs to come
back on but councillor siddal okay thank
you so i i am with councillor beal in
terms of recognizing council morris's
passion however councilman do you think
because of your behavior because of some
of the things that you've done
that you might have put other people off
becoming councillors
elsa morris
this councillor role is um i mean when i
when
when i first joined this council
i thought that an independent councillor
would be a good councillor because they
were obviously doing things for the the
right reasons they uh they were doing a
very difficult thing on their own as an
independent without the help of a big
political party because we all know the
big political parties do a hell of a lot
for you um as an independent you do your
own leaflets you do your own everything
you know that councillor siddal
um
now
i originally thought that there would be
perhaps 10 councillors in this council
of 31 that were
what i would call shirt fillers seat
warmers that were useless that turned up
for five percent of the meetings
um we've got a five
councillor duik five percent attendance
record oh my god 100 takes 100 percent
of the allowance though didn't he
um
[Music]
so
i i did think that there were a lot of
good people in the independence and even
when
there was serious bullying and serious
financial impropriety going on and most
of the
counsellors and yes i'm talking about
some of the people in this room
did nothing and i couldn't understand
that
but i
resolved in my own brain
that perhaps some councillors are here
to
to be able to deal with the financial
side of uh council work some councillors
might be here to diligently go through
the
reports and you know check the minutes
everyone has their own
area of expertise
my area of expertise happens to be
calling out twaddle and there was plenty
of it
now
most people that wish to be a counsellor
will also won't just need the motivation
to want to be the councillor they will
need to have integrity and they will
need to not be swayed
by um manipulating and insidious
officers and other councillors thank you
council mice and ask you to stop there
please as i said i'm going to have that
was the end of it but i will let
councillor schemes have one
last pop yes again i think it's a
question of
a misunderstanding when uh you've said
often that uh
officers who stood by when terrible
things have happened and so have
counsellors
but uh um in particular in the case of
the councillors when you know that
something is being done by other people
to address that thing you do not need to
step up and some people
maybe a majority of councillors do not
like to step into the uh
into the firing line while they do their
work in other ways um that seems fine to
me certain people are sort of
are people who will put their heads
above the parapet but others will not
others will seek alternative uh ways or
will
let it fall to others i think that's
natural in any council and in any
organization and i think we have to take
great care if we land up on some sort of
white charger accusing other people of
not doing their duty and
announcing that you yourself are the
great hero who is doing their duty
all people are bringing different things
to the whole council experience and i
just feel that it's important to
understand that some people
will stand up and
and make a noise and some people won't
and that's okay
thank you council skins i will allow
council morris to respond
thank you very much mr chairman um nick
uh i don't expect i didn't need anyone's
help
i didn't ask for anyone's help
but the problem i had was whilst i was
fighting
i've got you guys not even
trying to trying to help
yeah yeah yeah i'll go for that one nick
i mean nick you did you did some really
good stuff in the background
um you put together a few really good
reports
but ultimately almost everyone in this
room
stood there i mean we all know that
fluker did that loan
i'm sorry councilman i'll just yeah i'm
just finishing
when i appalled when i said that
no one stuck up for me okay i was shut
up in that meeting yeah i was vilified
in that meeting everyone knew it was the
truth
especially elaine banford
thank you and nobody councilman nobody
stuck up for you i've made your you made
your point thank you so um i would like
now to ask um
who would i like to ask i'm not really
sure here um
i
yes i'd like to ask mr mitchell is the
person i'd like to ask the independent
person and i would now invite you um to
give any advice you may have to the
committee please
thank you
chairman thank you members
um
firstly i'm just
my role i am
i'll consider myself to be an
independent person
um
and i've listened to the arguments put
forward
very carefully
and i'm particularly
pleased chrissy that you spoke out then
over
the last few questions and really gave
some background to yourself which
you know you hadn't responded in any way
and it was useful for me just to hear
that and i think you've had a fair
fair hearing today in front of everybody
and i'm pleased that you came forward
like that it's
always interesting could you speak up a
little bit sorry it's always interesting
to hear
what motivates people however i've had
to look at this
in the round if you like and the
allegations
and the reports in front of us do
indicate breaches of control with the
exception of the complaint about council
of voice
we've talked about
your appearance a year ago in this very
room and
the outcome of that and the changes that
you've made to yourself
i suppose my real
concern is when i asked
mr lewin this was the seriousness of the
whole corporate management team making a
complaint that's a bit of a lot to load
onto one person which has happened to
you but nonetheless that is a serious
matter for this committee to consider
and possibly for the council as well
and um i think you've got well
researched and written reports in front
of you and equally you've got the
evidence we've heard today
and um i said i have found that really
useful
but uh
my advice is this is there are some
serious allegations here that need your
full attention
and um
you know the strong weight must be that
there has been a breach of the code
uh how serious that is i think is a
metaphor for members to consider and
indeed if there has been at all i
suppose but i think there has been um
and uh
i will leave it there for now unless
anyone has any questions very much if
you think i've been unfair to you please
let me know thank you very much okay i
would now like to move uh to private
session so i shall say to resolve that
under section 100 a4
of the local government act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following item of business on the
grounds that it involves
the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph 1
and paragraph 6 of part 1 of schedule 12
a to the act and that's this satisfies
the public interest test
i propose that motion do i have a
seconder
thank you
do we can we agree that by a sense
agreed thank you so i will ask the press
and the public now to leave the chamber
i'm afraid that includes you as well
councilor morris and
you as well councillor
councillor morris i will ask you so
nicely it will be a lovely strokey nice
so if you wouldn't mind leaving the
chamber both of you
it will be very short i promise you i
will do it as quickly as we can but it
needs to be done fairly so we will we it
will take as long as it takes i'm afraid
and i think i need to go to the louvre
so can we can we um should we can we
come back in five minutes would that be
okay thank you
1604 thank you so welcome back to the
press and public
having listened to the various speakers
today we unanimously agree all the
findings of the investigating reports
and breaches of the code of conduct by
councillor morris are set out in the
reports
and we adopt the reasoning of the
investigating officers in their reports
in terms of sanctions we are proposing
to formally censure councillor morris
and we are going to restrict access to
it and email
the restriction to it will be so that
council morris can only contact the
council and councillors by a fresh serve
until the 1st of may 2022
we will write to you with formal censure
in the next few days
we recommend to the council
that councillor morris is removed from
all committees and working groups or
outside bodies i'm not on any means
although we have found serious breaches
of the code of conduct we note that
council moist does not appear to realize
how he comes across to others we would
therefore recommend that council morris
is provided with and accepts training on
conflict management and resolving
disputes
those are the findings of the committee
are you going to remove me from
committees and working groups when i'm
not on any
can i get a letter essential please i'd
like to work as a hat to the next
council meeting
yeah i would like to actually i can just
find the blooming prompts there we are
members thank you for your contributions
this afternoon i now draw the meeting to
a close do i not get a right reply mr
chairman
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion and please leave the meeting
by the exit door behind the top table
thank you
you